Welcome back to Oblivion.
Hello.
Hello, I'm still sleepy.
It's a...
I never stream this early.
Hey, Mint, you're finally awake.
I'm not!
Happy belated not birthday.
Aw, thank you.
Oblivion theme cover win.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-ba-bom-bom-bom-bom.
And dum-dum-dum.
He-he-he.
Hello!
Coffee time.
I do have a coffee.
Right here.
Luckily, I will turn it down a little bit.
There we go.
Yeah!
Uh, we're back with more Oblivion!
More sneaking!
More...
uh...
Death!
More...
But not me...
Hahaha!
More!
Uh... Uh... Uh... Uh... Lockpicking!
My murder!
More!
Cop, cop, cop, cop, cop!
Of course, more Itina.
She's our girl!
Hahaha!
Don't say lick-pocking!
I had to really think about it!
Hahaha!
I feel like I'm just gonna...
You know how when you accidentally mistype something so many times in your phone?
And then it's like, oh, you obviously mean this now.
I feel like my brain is going to overwrite lockpicking to lick-pocking.
And I'm just not gonna be able to...
I will be able to function!
Hahaha!
It's how language evolves.
I don't...
I think it's just me!
Hahaha!
I don't think it's a language thing!
Wait, so does that mean if I had little ghost children...
Then they would also evolve to say...
Lick-pocking.
And then if they had ghost children...
Then it would become...
They would also say...
Lick-pocking.
And then it would spread!
Your children evolve!
Hahaha!
Ah!
I already have that on my list of things to do, though.
It's to self-evolve.
Eventually.
Maybe.
What do you mean, huh?
No, don't evolve children!
Evolve me!
I want to...
Evolve.
It doesn't evolve children.
Involve!
It doesn't involve children!
I want to evolve like I'm a Pokémon.
You can lick as many pox as you want.
What?
Is lick a bad word?
Hahaha!
Or wait...
Is that supposed to be lock?
Oh, no.
Wait, I can't tell!
Necromancy is banned!
No!
Spamming bee to stop evolution!
Nooo!
Don't!
Don't hold me back!
Let me become my full potential!
Hahaha!
Let me reach my full potential!
What would you evolve into?
I don't know!
That's the exciting part!
Nooo!
Hahaha!
I got blocked trying to say lick!
Eww!
YouTube thinks it's a little freaky, maybe.
Ice cream, Chibi Minto!
Why am I ice cream?
Why?
Can't believe Minto is back to lick our pox.
That sounds bad, though.
Don't say it like that!
Also, hello, Gerardo!
Welcome back!
Can you evolve to Gengar if we trade you over the link cable?
What if I...
What if...
I've...
You...
The cable is...
Optional.
Right?
Are you like a Digimon?
Mintymon...
Digital Ghost...
Digital Ghost is the champion!
Yes...
Anyway...
It's been a minute since I last played Oblivion.
Let's load the game.
Hello, E.T.
and I...
It must be this autosave.
Wait, where...
I'm in the church.
What was I doing?
It's been almost a month since I last played, you guys!
Look at that!
Save...
Oh, my big head is blocking the way.
The save date was June 15th!
You know what?
That means we will just...
Do whatever we want to do!
We don't have...
We are not bound by...
Previous attempts.
Your chibi looks like one of those Spongebob Ice Pops.
What about now?
Wait...
Now...
Okay, I'm like the Ice Pops that...
Hold on...
There we go...
I'm one of the Ice Pops that...
Are deformed...
It melted before you opened the package.
But those...
Never seem to work, huh?
Starting to melt them a bit.
It's a treat to witness your return, E-Tina.
I can't open that shack.
Everybody...
Say hi!
Why?
Oh wait!
We got a new outfit!
Why are we wearing a hood?
To distract from our beautiful hair?
What did I do?
The shrouded hood.
No armor.
Hi!
Hi, E-Tina!
You're looking as magnificent as you have always looked.
Look at that.
E-Tina!
The hood was an armor bonus.
I believe so, too.
Now it just looks like E-T!
I think this...
Ruins the disguise!
E-Tina!
Phone home!
Is E-Tina just E-T with a wig?
No!
What?
That's...
That would be ridiculous!
And that was your whole point.
What?
Crazy!
No!
Obviously...
E-Tina is a wood elf, and not an alien from another planet.
No!
Obviously, E-Tina is not from space!
And not E-T!
She's a wood elf!
She's nimble and quick!
With the hood on E-T, she get blamed for all her crimes.
Perfect disguise!
Oh wait!
That's actually such a genius!
That's so genius, actually!
Meet the phone home!
Let's see...
There's one big thing I really want to do...
And that's...
Get a house!
Especially the haunted house!
I know that is one gold that I've always had!
And it's...
We need what?
5,000 gold?
Wait!
I'm only 2,000 away!
Has anyone seen E-T and E-Tina in the same room before?
Every house I live in is haunted!
Yeah, but not in...
Game!
E-Tina is not a ghost!
I shouldn't be talking to these guys!
How do you do?
No, don't talk to me!
I'm...
I remember last time I would talk...
Stand clear!
Last time I would talk to them, they'd try to arrest me!
I don't remember why!
I...
I'm traumatized now!
Let's see...
Okay, let's go to the map...
Okay, we're all the way here because we were at the brotherhood...
With our brothers...
Our devilish brothers and sisters...
It's in...
Kvatch, right?
Enter the Eliminator...
I must accept a contract for Mochiva...
This one!
Anvil!
You're so right!
Let's just travel here...
You can see if you're...
If you have a bounty...
On the character screen...
Oh, you're right!
I did learn that last time too, I think...
Oh!
Suddenly it's daytime!
Okay, hold on...
Let's see...
Character...
Do I have a bounty?
Uh...
Oh, I think it's here, right?
I don't have a bounty!
Shivering Isles bounty...
Why is my infamy 11?
I'm the hero of that one city!
My fame should be like 500!
Who are you?
I'm Arvina Thales...
They call me...
The Rat Lady...
On account of all my pet rats...
Oh...
Because of your pet rats, huh?
You can't imagine the fuss...
Some people make...
My rats are no problem for anyone!
I bet...
I want to be her friend...
Farewell!
Goodbye!
They're so unhinged in this game!
This is the house I want, no?
Yes...
Yes?
Count arms...
No?
Who are you?
Greetings to you!
Are you the man...
No...
Horse...
Dead Ear?
Is this the house I want?
Yes, it is!
You can go into our house and find all the rats...
Are they like the giant ass rats?
That manor is still for sale...
If you're interested...
My eyes are here!
If you want to buy Beneris manor...
It's still available for a modest price...
I want it!
No questions asked...
Please!
Can we...
Yes, here's 5,000 gold!
You don't even have enough money!
Stop wasting my time and come back when you do!
Okay...
He can't stop...
Maybe he's got like a lazy eye...
I'm in his lap right now...
Hey, what if I...
What did I just do?
I pressed C...
I was just trying to crouch...
What if I give you a little special service?
E-Tina style!
He doesn't care...
He's eating his bread...
Hello, good sir!
Oh!
Hello!
I used an invisibility scroll!
Oh, I'm gonna reload...
Wait, F...
F9...
Sorry, it's been so long since I've played...
Wait!
I used an invisibility scroll and they...
He still talked to me...
It's your birthday!
Happy birthday!
I wish I could tell you what your name is...
But instead of...
YouTube's going by these...
Stupid...
At...
Signs...
Now...
So...
DSM, happy birthday!
Can I leave or...
F9 reloads the quick save...
Not the auto save...
Okay, then let's just...
Load...
Why are they blocking the door?
I don't know!
That's what I'm asking!
Okay...
Don't use my invisibility...
Because it's precious...
Alright, I'll come back with your five...
Five thousand...
Hello, good...
Buckaroos...
I'll be...
I'll be back!
And then...
Oh, my goodness!
Oh, there they are!
Which is the house, even, that I want?
Can I still go inside?
Is this it?
By the church...
A third Sextius!
Fighters Guild...
I'm running, I'm running...
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running...
Climb!
Nice!
Oh, wait!
Was it this one?
Yes!
No, I don't need the...
It can be...
It can be picked...
Please!
Let me in!
Alright, well, what we'll do...
Is we'll...
Do some...
Caves...
Around this area...
So that we're nice and close...
And, um...
Yeah!
So we can go here!
Oh!
I guess I'll just fast travel, easy!
Dungeon time!
I'm gonna have to remember how to play this game!
The cave leads under Castle Anvil...
Wait, what?
What?
That one?
Right there?
Wait...
Is this...
Is this a dungeon?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Um...
Okay!
I don't re...
I still remember this?
Smuggler's Cave.
Well, they should have some good stuff, no?
Right?
Should have some good stuff.
The music is not ominous yet, so maybe it's safe.
Okay...
Yarn...
Oh, I hear a Nurn Root.
So far, not so good.
Oh, wait.
Okay...
Wait, wait.
Pickaxe.
Oh, yeah.
I hear it.
I hear the stinking flower.
Where are you?
Okay, that looks ominous.
Nothing here?
Oh, my gosh.
It's all a bunch of junk.
Wait, where's the root?
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
You guys hear it too?
Am I crazy?
I...
I only hear, like, over here.
Maybe it's above ground.
For those annoyed by YouTube switching your chat handle to the weird at name, you can alter your name and channel settings so they can be the same.
Please do!
Otherwise, I don't recognize people.
It makes me so sad.
Hisashimuri Ichina-san.
My brain is full of umamusume.
Just finished season two and it's so peak.
Excited to see more lockpicking.
Yes!
Lockpicking!
You guys hear the root?
I hear it.
Ah!
I found it.
Okay.
Onwards into the cave.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Oh my god!
Nevermind!
There is no cave!
We got baited!
Get me out of here.
Stinky.
What are these?
They're pretty.
Whoa!
There's a bunch of bugs even.
I'm gonna grab them with...
Okay.
Well, now, I'm not quite sure what to do.
I guess we'll explore until we find...
A dungeon.
We'll explore until we find a dungeon, I suppose.
Um...
There's gotta be something around here.
There's...
Dogs barking.
Hmm...
YouTube changing names.
Yeah, as you can see in the chat, they're all like...
Ads or whatever.
So annoying.
I wonder what my at looks like.
Is it at Mint Phantom?
Or is it just a bunch of...
I've never...
I don't remember ever change...
Oh!
What are they doing?
At Mint Phantom.
Oh!
Okay, it is.
There's not another deer there!
Oh my goodness.
I thought I was about to get...
I thought YouTube was about to get really mad at me.
Sextius!
Okay, we're looking for a cave, everybody.
We're looking for...
A place to pillage.
I mean...
Not pillage.
Sorry.
Oh wait!
That looks like...
An area over there.
Test.
Your test has been received.
What?
Do you want me to grade you too?
What are we bandits?
No!
We're so much more respectable than that.
Fort!
Oh!
Is that a bad...
Is that a bad dog?
I think so.
Oops.
Whoa!
Wait, is this his dog?
Wait...
There's someone talking.
Where'd my other arrow go?
I don't see it.
Ah!
Show me what you've got!
Oh, dang it.
Wait, why are you...
Ouch!
Have you to pieces!
Stupid!
Leave me alone!
I guess he was the guy talking.
Do you own that horrible place?
Whoa!
He's got a lot of arrow.
Nice.
Take his potion.
Oh!
Steel dagger!
That's...
Can sell for...
A good amount, right?
Okay!
Oh!
Ah!
We found one!
Let's go in.
Hopefully there's some good loot in here.
Why are the...
Why is the music always so scary in these...
Ah!
In these places.
Are you gonna notice me?
Ah!
I can't tell which way they're facing.
Oh, not towards me.
Maybe?
Wait.
They are facing towards me.
Oh!
You think they're a friend?
I missed my chance.
Stood there for...
10 minutes.
Leave it to YouTube to make some of the weirdest changes.
I know, right?
Nobody asks for this.
I think he'll...
Oh!
Jump on my sword while you can.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
Jump on my sword while you can.
What was...
Wow!
What does that mean?
Sir?
Okay!
Oh!
Wait!
These are worth a lot.
But it's gonna be really heavy.
Hold on.
We'll see what...
What we can take.
This is also worth a lot.
Alright.
Mister!
I know I just...
I...
I also made you bald.
Um...
I know that like...
That like...
I just stripped you of your clothes.
But I'm not going to...
Jump on your sword.
Oh my gosh.
That scared the hecky out of me.
Are you gonna come through or...
No?
You're just gonna be really mysterious?
These guys are tough!
Look!
I even cooked them over the open flame!
These guys scared...
Wait!
These are all...
Their...
Their stuff is worth so much!
Maybe I should just...
Loot these guys...
Of their clothes...
And then...
Sell it all!
I'm gonna be...
Overweight at this point!
Okay...
Oh wait...
What's my...
What am I looking at?
Um...
Wait...
Okay...
295!
Um...
Well, we're close to town, right?
Maybe I can just go sell it real quick.
Oh, this scared me.
I thought it was a person.
Ghosts have way...
We don't...
Oh...
I thought other...
Nope...
That's not what I meant to do...
There we go...
There's a dead guy right there!
Dead?
Wait...
Dead...
Right?
Dead?
Sleep?
Gold!
Oh...
That's like a...
Okay...
I think that's dead.
Wait!
Okay...
Take this...
I know we're gonna be...
Overweight...
Okay...
Now we run...
Now we leave...
And we'll go sell...
Look at the cake on that man...
Alright...
I think your first arrow missed and hit the...
That...
This guy...
Oh...
No kidding!
Oh wait...
Baby...
That would be crazy!
I'm a secret genius!
Actually...
It's not so much a secret anymore now...
Is it?
Yeah...
Totally on purpose!
There I go...
Well as soon as I leave...
We can just...
We can...
Quick...
We can quick...
Travel...
You are now looting...
Oblivion style...
No kidding!
Am I doing it right?
Alright...
Now...
Oh wait...
My bad...
Just kidding!
You guys...
Um...
Isn't it nice though?
When we get to just hang out for a long amount of time...
You know?
Isn't it nice that we can just...
Enjoy...
The scenery...
And the journey together?
Walking simulator...
What in the Death Stranding is this?
Definitely...
Yeah!
This is why horse is good...
I don't know where my horse is...
Now we're playing Death Stranding...
Finally!
Oh...
I've thought about it...
I was like...
Maybe I should play Death Stranding...
The first game...
Off stream...
Cause I...
Will get through it...
More quickly...
Especially if I have more days off...
Or if I just play Death Stranding...
No talking...
I could just...
Have my mic off...
I don't know...
I just really wanna play...
But...
Right now...
Because I'm trying to rest my...
Voice as much as possible...
It's like...
Well then I can't...
Play for a long time...
It was really sleepy...
Last night...
I got a notification...
For a voicemail...
From Mint...
That's from my phone provider...
Mint Mobile...
I have your phone number...
Oh...
Wow...
Lucky...
Lucky find...
Okay...
That is...
The castle...
We're trying to go find a store...
Hopefully there's one in here...
She has...
Actually I'm the owner of Mint Mobile...
That's me...
No mic streamers...
Okay...
Really?
Come on...
Okay...
Let's see...
Let's find a little store in here...
Ah...
Chapel...
House...
Manor...
Guild...
Can I sell things at the guild...
Or would it be better?
Probably...
Abandoned house...
Many homes...
House...
That's a peacemaker...
Uh oh...
You're Ryan Gosling?
Oh my gosh...
You're Ryan...
I forgot that guy owns it...
He owns Mint Mobile...
Count...
Arms maybe...
No wait...
That's a...
Hotel, no?
Uh oh...
Is there like...
No store here?
Wait...
Where should I sell?
There's a store...
Outside on the docks...
Oh thank you...
Oh it's Ryan Reynolds...
You guys got it wrong then...
You guys said Gosling...
You guys said Ryan Gosling...
Head to the...
Oh...
Even with that voice...
Death Stranding is goofy on its own...
So...
Yes...
I will...
Look at that bug...
Whoa...
Oh...
There...
What's happening to him?
What's happening to you?
Is...
I'm like an...
Oh...
Never mind...
He was stuck in an invisible string...
Okay...
Good thing...
We don't have to swim...
Because I think I might actually sink...
It's...
Mejito Ryan...
No...
She's my enemy right now...
I'm not over it...
I'm not over...
My huge loss to Mejito Ryan...
No Mike Death Stranding...
It might be really nice...
I'll probably get hit with every copyright...
DMCA ever...
But that's okay...
I got hit with one recently...
It was so funny...
I got hit with a DMCA...
For a...
For a member stream...
Back in 2020...
They really just trying to...
Take every...
Nickel and dime from me...
Is this...
This looks like an inn...
The warehouse?
Is that it?
Maybe...
Or...
What is that?
This looks like a store...
Too many Ryans...
Maybe their names are fake...
You remind me of a witch I once knew...
I hate witches...
Okay...
You're a literal worm...
I don't think you have anything to say...
You remind me of a worm I once knew...
God...
Leave me alone...
I'm just existing...
They call me Wilhelm the Worm...
Because dirt suits me fine...
Town lets me live in the warehouse...
To keep out the rats...
Then you should be Wilhelm the Cat...
What?
You got any rumors?
I don't like you...
And I don't want to talk to you...
Why is everybody so rude?
I'm done talking to you...
I was not...
Okay...
We need to wait...
They closed early...
So we need to stand here for 12 hours...
I'm sure Wilhelm will be really pleased about that...
Wilhelm...
The asshole...
Got him...
Oh...
Look who else has been standing here...
Staring at me all night...
Don't bother me again...
And you might live to regret it...
You're an actual freak...
Please leave me alone...
Oh my god...
She's got jokes...
Hello...
Norbert...
What do you want?
Do you have wares?
Oh...
Bartering...
Wait, we must make you like me first...
Go ahead...
Do you?
Oh...
Shoot...
Unlucky...
Uh...
I can't argue with that...
Really now...
You're such a charmer...
I'm a charmer...
Uh oh...
Gosh...
You're a big fat liar...
What a dumb joke...
A phony...
Okay, we went down a little bit...
But...
I'm just getting back into it...
A big phony...
A big fat phony...
Okay, here we go...
You're pathetic...
Oh my god...
Sorry, I don't get it...
Really now...
You win this one...
Okay, we went up one point...
From...
What's with this mustache...
What's with this whole...
Everything...
I'm not...
I'm not one to judge...
People by their appearance and all...
But...
If they're rude to me...
That's why you're so ugly...
You're a big fat liar...
Ugly...
Inside...
And out...
Oh shoot...
I mean...
What a dumb joke...
I messed that up...
That's my bad...
Oh...
Geez...
Sorry, I don't get it...
Cheese Louise...
Please...
I'm embarrassed...
Don't make me...
I can't argue with that...
Okay...
We did that one really well...
That one was super duper lucky...
Okay...
And I can't do anymore...
Cool...
Perfect...
Put your...
Weapon away for a bonus...
Really?
I see...
Yep...
Be seeing you...
My speech craft went up...
A pleasure to speak...
Um...
Rumors?
Rufrius Venetius is good with his fists...
I've seen him in action...
And it's impressive...
Rufrius...
What's his name?
Rufrius Venetius is good with his fists...
You don't even sound like you...
I'm saying it correctly...
I've seen him in action...
And it's impressive...
Ruf...
Rufrius...
Wait, let's see if I can make him nice...
Tell me more...
Wait...
He likes me so much more now...
Okay...
We are so good...
You have reached the maximum disposition for this character...
Let's go...
Okay...
I offer the finest goods and lowest prices in all Cyrodiil...
Thank you...
For...
Who told me...
To...
Put away my weapon...
We are so in...
Okay...
Alright...
Um...
Disposition...
79...
Buying items...
Uh...
Selling...
At 55% of value...
No...
57...
56%...
56% of value...
And I won't budge...
Okay...
Um...
Let's see...
This...
Sell...
That's a fair deal...
Ah...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
D-d-d-dum.
Now higher?
Really?
58!
And I won't back down.
This one, this is the dwarven bow is the one that we stole.
After we killed that man.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, um... What else did we take?
Steal... Oh wait, actually let's go with weight first.
Okay.
Keep the dwarven bow?
Oh.
Oops.
Oh well.
Dwarven bow was pretty good.
I like mine though, the shadow hunt.
Oh my gosh, I have an itch on my leg!
You can buy
it back.
But I don't want... Oh wait, it is pretty good.
Compared to mine.
But it's expensive.
It's fine.
Okay.
I think that's everything we took.
We didn't take that much.
We didn't really take that much.
It just... I kind of was like, oh, let's get out of here.
Potion of cure disease.
I guess we just gotta go back.
Meh.
Oh wait!
We took...
There was a dagger.
I remember.
I was like, oh, I can sell this.
I have this thing.
Suffer thorn.
It's better than the dagger.
We'll sell these dagger.
Do I need these boots?
Did I steal these too?
Sell potions?
They're heavy?
Are they really?
What's that?
Well, I mean...
I guess...
They're not that heavy!
They're .5!
That one is better than the dwarven bow, but it's enchanted so the enchantment will wear out unless you're keeping it fed with souls.
How do I do that?
They add up quickly.
I do have like 10 potions of sorcery and I don't even really use magicka.
So...
Soul gems with souls in them.
The mage's guild can restock.
Guys!
We are so close!
1000 gold away.
Woohoo!
What else do we got?
Wait, wait.
Buy weight, not weight.
I guess I could sell like half of the potions of healing.
I have a lot of them.
But those I will actually use.
Potion of personality.
Hahaha!
Get a personality bub.
You don't need that?
What are you saying I'm chiming?
All on my own?
You're saying that I'm...
I'm...
I have a great personality without even...
Without even...
Doing a potion.
Without even fortifying myself.
I don't need to cheat code my personality.
That I'm just a real natural charmer.
I can't go by.
Mercantile mastery increase.
Negotiation, bargaining...
D... D... D...
Dickering!
E-Tida!
This potion of personality, just alcohol.
You're okay, I guess.
Charles Dickens.
Haggling, they're all means to an end.
Getting the best price for your goods.
The damage condition of an item is no longer a factor when you sell it.
Merchants may also offer you better items.
I didn't know that the condition was a factor.
There.
Wow.
Yay!
A thing that I...
Didn't know about.
Alright.
Let's go back to that...
Come back and see me again.
Thank you, Norbert.
Goodbye.
Let's go back to that cave.
And go grab some more armor.
I'm gonna hold on to the other potions for now.
Just...
Wait, what's mine?
Actually...
Okay, we're...
We're like a little over half of what we could hold, but...
How are you?
This town is haunted.
Wait, are you not...
The worm?
Oh, you just asked how I was.
He likes me now.
What's your story?
So...
We'll just keep stealing armor and coming back.
I think.
You're growing on him.
Maybe, like...
The other guy is his bestie.
And he was like...
My bestie is...
Cool with you.
I'm cool with you.
You know?
You had your bow out.
You really hate that, huh?
Why can't I just be...
Prepared for anything?
You know?
Maybe that's why.
Put your bow away and I love you.
Alright.
Sneak time.
What is save again?
F5?
Right?
Thank you.
Sorry.
It's been a month.
I'm remembering stuff.
No way.
Why are his hands like that?
Get it?
Cuz people ask me.
Why are my hands like that?
Just a little...
A little funny.
Why are...
Oh, that's a rat.
My...
I feel...
Well, you can't really see it.
Hold on.
Let me scoot over.
My bow is already almost to like...
Half...
Enchantment.
I'm kind of nervous.
How do I get a souls gem?
I looked right at it!
Oh, golly.
I'll be okay.
I didn't get hurt.
We're fine.
No!
Oh, okay.
Nothing here.
Wait.
Okay, fine.
Do you not have any souls gems?
I think you can normally steal them from the mages guild.
Maybe...
I saw some of you guys say that I have some.
So maybe...
How do I...
Use them then?
Via...
How do I use them?
Can I use them like right here?
Souls gem...
Maybe not under alchemy...
All right up here.
We'll just go in.
Alphabet...
Wait.
Oh!
Petty soul gem!
Is that ET?
It is!
Well...
It's ETina!
You need a soul...
For this soul gem.
Those ones are empty.
What is this?
Is it a full soul gem?
Lesser...
Soul...
Gem?
These places still scare the...
Scare me.
I don't like it.
This is why I've been putting it off for so long.
I get freaked out in these places, you guys.
I'm not meant for the...
Dungeon cave dwelling life.
I'm...
I'm a lady.
I don't hear anyone walking.
What's in here?
The Great Dome.
I'm too freaked out by these places.
I don't like going in by myself.
I get scared.
Okay.
Careful.
Easy.
I don't want to fall down there.
Okay, never mind.
Not easy.
Up...
Upsy daisy.
I'm going in further and further.
That makes me even more nervous that there's nobody around.
What if I encounter a ghost?
A...
Ghost!
You gotta chat with you?
Yeah.
Be my...
Um...
My...
What's the word?
Where's all the people that I can steal the armor from?
Wait.
I'll take this, chill.
Be my...
My moral support!
What?
Where the heck is this going?
Gold!
Look who we've got here.
Oh, shoot.
The other girl just goes, huh?
Huh?
If she was here a second ago...
Money!
Your presence here will not be tolerated.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Well, well, look who we've got here.
Where are you?
Got her!
Okay.
Nice!
Nice, nice.
Alright.
Take that.
Um...
I know she missed a couple more times.
Guess there's nobody else here.
Nice.
You guys are just chilling down here?
Take your...
Linens!
Wait, what if I take her linens?
Gotta use a soul trap spell on a creature.
Kill it, then use the soul as fuel from the...
For the...
From the soul gem.
You can also use a welkin soul...
Stone.
Ah, yeah, but...
Will it...
That...
I was told to keep those.
I think for some quest, eventually.
That bow is a shotgun.
You blasted that first guy into the wall.
Hatsumito!
My...
Gamerslips...
Mito mousepad came in.
Ah!
I'm glad!
Thank you for ordering it!
Also, Ducky, thank you for the gifted.
Should I take the dagger, too?
We can always...
Ditch it if...
Eventually...
We have too much...
On hand, you know?
Wow!
That one's worth a lot.
Wait, what is my health at, anyway?
Oh!
Perfect.
Okay!
Silver!
Silver arrow...
What's my inventory?
Yuck and Ike...
Okay, we got 50.
Silver...
Fancy, baby!
Silver bow!
What do you have?
Anything?
I love a lizard lady.
Silver arrows work on ghosts.
Oh!
I was gonna ask...
How do I defeat them?
How many...
Let's see, should I switch to the silver arrows?
I have a lot of iron arrows.
I guess I could get rid of some of them now...
Since we're...
Well...
I don't have so many...
Steel...
I'll...
I'll save the...
I'll do the steel until...
Maybe we encounter some ghosts...
But I can't...
I can't stay for too long now...
Cause I...
I looted too much!
Oh, whoops.
I said it was empty.
I'm stupid.
The music is so...
Indiana Jones...
To me.
Yeah, we're going into the...
Into the dome.
Okay.
I'm scared.
No!
There's multiple people!
Uh-oh.
My bow is really about to be not enchanted anymore.
Okay.
Dang it.
What...
Where'd you go?
Where did he go?
...prevalent into Somerset Isle?
It seems...
...Somerset Isle...
...has become a much more dangerous place...
...and be seeing you.
Hello!
Good afternoon.
The Imperial city is located on a...
...large island...
...surrounded by Lake Rumar.
Really?
What's the news...
Yes...
Yes!
I still got it.
I still got it!
Can they see my bow?
Okay, there we go.
I think he's broken!
Oh, he's not broken anymore, okay.
Oh shoot.
Where'd he go?
Where?
Hello?
Oh shoot.
Wait a second!
You guys, this is huge!
Oh my god!
This is huge!
Cave diver's helmet.
Wait, this is huge!
This is huge!
His little clogs!
Big money!
I don't know if I can take the boots.
Hold on.
I'm over encumbered.
Okay.
Let's see.
What can we throw away that's not worth a bajillion dollars?
Oh!
There we go.
Holy moly!
Okay.
Uh...
This should be enough for us to...
To buy our house!
No!
Use the repair hammers!
Oh, that's a good idea, right?
We can use it on our bow.
Where are they?
Repair hammers.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
The stolen ones!
I'll use first.
Yeah!
Oh, wait!
This...
I should repair it to full capacity, no?
Only an apprentice armorer.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh!
Hmm.
Oh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, it doesn't matter if we're selling anymore.
You literally told me that earlier, huh?
Oh...
I can't even repair my bow.
You can level armor by repairing everything.
Oh, interesting.
Well, I'll just repair...
This.
I kinda wanted to get rid of...
Them anyway, because they were stolen, and I don't want them to be like, We're taking your stolen goods!
You know?
Okay.
What do we do?
Let's get rid of...
Uh...
There was, like, some boots.
The iron...
Whoa!
No!
That's not what I wanted to do.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
Um...
Hold on.
How do I...
Hold
on!
One moment, please.
Put back on...
Tina!
You put your armor back on right now!
Right this instant!
Okay, we're good.
How do I drop stuff again?
I can't remember how to drop things.
Oh, shoot.
Um...
I have some grapes.
I can get rid of...
Right...
Right click.
Ew, I forgot about the boots.
No, I didn't!
I didn't forget about the boots!
Hold on!
Here we go, here we go.
No, not right click.
What is it?
Control...
Oh, I see.
Shift, left, drop.
Got it.
Literally says at the bottom.
I'm speaking for my friend who is too busy to watch your live streams.
Oh, no!
He became a VTuber, so they don't have time to watch you.
Congrats on your friend becoming a VTuber!
She also dropped the iron armor.
But it's worth so much money!
I guess we'll get a lot of money.
From the helmet.
Okay, we'll drop...
Wait.
We can drop one.
And then we just need to only drop six.
More pounds.
Okay.
E-Tina's intense workout regime.
Let's see.
Routine.
Okay.
What's something that we can get rid of?
I guess we could also get rid of the silver bow.
It's not worth that much either.
Your greed is weighing you down.
I know!
You think I want to be this way?
There are more enemies to loot that may have better gear.
I feel like I can just leave though.
This is...
This dwarven...
...stuff is so heavy.
So, so heavy.
I guess we can get rid of this.
No!
That's not what I wanted to do.
Gosh, look at her legs.
I keep doing this.
Okay.
Shift.
Drop the bows.
Put on...
The armor.
I guess I'll drop it.
There might be...
Maybe...
There's somebody with good...
Good...
Um...
Oops!
Nobody heard that, right?
I'm afraid there's one more person here.
It sounded like three people were talking.
Where did he go?
We lost him.
That scared me.
Holy cow!
Okay, hold on.
It's all thanks to my...
Good armor though.
Okay.
There we go.
Quick save.
Alright.
Nothing to worry about, I guess.
Just my eyes playing tricks on me.
Ah!
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh!
I can't get him!
Ah!
Goodness gracious.
Uh oh, my...
Arrow...
Or my bow is not enchanted anymore.
But I make...
Where?
Ah!
Shoot.
You die!
Oh shoot.
What's the matter getting tired?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Yes.
Holy cow.
Okay, this guy is gonna be...
Yeah, give me all your stuff.
Give me your dwarven things.
I'm just...
I'm stripping you naked.
Uh oh, I'm over encumbered.
Okay.
Let's get rid of stuff.
Uhhh...
What can I get rid of?
Ah!
Tree Bobber!
It's gonna be my birthday in two days!
But I'm not gonna be online then.
Can I ask for a premature happy birthday?
I'm certain that I'll manage to survive the two days until then.
Okay.
I'm...
It's not jinxing it.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Tree Bobber!
Dwarf Armor!
Yeah, Dwarf Armor is super heavy, but it's...
Super...
Expensive.
Hey!
Let's get rid of these daggers.
They are not...
Very heavy, but...
Oh gosh, I have to get rid of 30 pounds worth of stuff.
Um...
I think I'm gonna have to abandon something.
I'm gonna have to abandon something.
Maybe the boots...
And...
No, that's only 20.
Ah!
Wait, what do these add up to?
One...
Hold on.
We're gonna...
We're doing real math here.
115 times 3 is 345, which is less than the 400 that is the cure-ass.
So...
I say we...
Get rid of the 3.
Look at the Daedra hearts.
They heal me.
They're only worth 2.
I guess that's 20, huh?
You know what?
You're so right.
Goodbye.
Alright, now we just need to get rid of 8.
So if I get rid of...
The gauntlets...
Ah!
Dang it, I did it again!
Get out of here!
Okay!
Whispering, drop the iron cure-ass.
Wait, where is it?
I don't even see it.
Huh?
Do I have that?
I don't...
I got rid of it already!
I don't have that!
You're crazy!
There is no iron one in here.
We need a flashbang emote.
Okay.
Nice.
Take my arrow back.
What the heck is a rock shatter?
When the vow breaks...
I've come across an unusual mace named Rock Shatter.
On the body of a Nord, the mace has a worn inscription on the haft reading to Maeva and...
Bajalfi.
In honor of your union.
I should hang onto this weapon.
I'm sure Maeva will want to know her late husband's fate.
Who's Maeva?
Wait, am I over encumbered again?
Gosh, dang it!
It's too heavy!
I should hold on to this.
Immediately drops it.
Wait, I'm barely...
That's so unfair.
Okay, hold on.
We can get rid of like...
Where's my...
Where's my arrows?
Here we go.
Let's get rid of like...
Like...
50 of them.
Now we're good.
My bad I'm crazy.
Yeah, I've dropped it!
It's okay.
You haven't fed your horses in three days?
Okay.
It sucks I'm going to go check this lady, but I know that I won't be able to take anything.
Well, she also doesn't have that much stuff anyway, so...
Let's get out of here.
Let's go sell all this stuff.
And...
Let's become rich and buy a house.
Yippee!
Okay.
I don't remember how to leave.
Not that way.
This way.
Oh, I remember how to leave.
I haven't gone that way, but...
We can check that on the way...
When we come in again.
Oh my gosh!
We're home owners!
What made that sounds?
Was that... Tina?
What is it now?
I just...
Wait...
What?
What's happening?
What was...
Someone was getting attacked, I think.
Eh?
What was that?
What?
It came from over here?
I think?
Mud crab fight?
You think that's what that was?
You think someone died to a mud crab?
It was... We first heard the... Right here.
The first one was you.
But that sounded like a man.
No?
That was the most like... Voice.
Tina is a... She's...
She's got a dainty voice.
And then I kept hearing it happening.
Even when I was... What a mystery.
It kept happening though.
You guys heard it, no?
It's not bad.
What?
I said it's not bad.
Rufus Venetius is good with his fists.
I've seen him in action and it's impressive.
This guy is getting around everywhere with his fists, huh?
What are they standing around for?
Alright.
Let's sell and become rich.
Do you still like us?
A pleasure to speak with you.
You still like us, Norbert?
Take your time.
82.
I think that's about... Can I interest you in some of my wares?
I think that's what it was about before.
Let's try 59.
Alright.
Here we go!
Wait.
Should I hold on to this cave diver's helmet?
Can I even use it?
Because it says I can have water breathing.
Anyway.
Let's sell this.
Yes!
I'm gonna try 60.
Let's sell this.
A fine transaction.
Let's try 61.
This?
62.
Oh my gosh!
You guys, look how close we are!
63.
An excellent bargain.
64.
I'm gonna be broke for 5!
5!
What else did I grab?
I can't remember.
Is there anything else I grabbed?
I grabbed the pearl.
The pearl?
I'm gonna get rid of those.
We have our Lusia Argonian maid.
Pleasure to serve you.
Thank you!
Goodbye!
Nice!
Alright.
Let's go get ourselves a haunted house, baby!
Wee!
Holy cow!
Is that the guy?
The children are starving.
Hello.
Please help.
Everybody's talking about the prophet.
Go ahead.
After the attack on the chapel, people are inclined to believe almost anything.
Today's your lucky day.
Is that so?
So let's hear it.
Everybody's talking about it.
What?
I can't bring attention.
My god.
Alright.
The voices.
Okay.
Ikimasu.
All the same voice actor too.
The voices!
Hello there.
Hello.
Hear me!
Oh, people of Syracuse!
You will be my...
Gosh!
This is a really nice house.
We've got a little...
Look how romantic the balcony is.
We can just go on top and...
Kind of stare wistfully into the...
You know...
Into the...
Into the world.
And just think like...
Ah!
Aw, yeah!
It was...
Here?
The Count's...
Arms.
Wait.
There?
Oh, yeah.
I was so close.
Okay.
Hello!
Hello, good lady.
Wait a second.
Who are you?
Jesson Sextius.
Singer, composer, and storyteller extraordinaire.
Glad to meet you.
I'm not glad to meet you.
Good day.
Oh, there you are.
What is it?
You, you, you.
Manor is still for sale if you're interested.
Another Sextius.
Gosh.
They're living up to their name.
If you want to buy Benorist Manor, it's still available for a modest price.
Is that really a modest price in this game?
5,000 gold?
Interested?
I don't know.
It seems pretty steep, no?
It is.
The other cheapest is 10K.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Excellent.
Here's the key to the front door and the deed of ownership.
I hope you enjoy your new home.
It took seven parts, everybody, but we're finally here.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I must attend to those pressing matters I spoke of earlier.
Good day.
Good day!
You wear the shadows well, fellow thief.
Oh.
You're a fellow thief.
Goodbye.
Shadow hide you.
There's a man sitting right there that heard everything you said.
He's gonna go report us.
I bought a house!
I bought a house.
A haunted house.
Oh my gosh, it's a spirit property.
What happened here?
Why is it haunted?
Consider the difference in price between weapons and houses in the US.
What do you mean?
Here we go.
I hope it's furnished.
I've arrived at my new house in Anvil Beneris Manor.
Looks like the place may need some work, but it was a great deal.
I just couldn't pass up.
I can now make myself at home.
Oh.
Why is there a...
Why?
Right there.
Why a table right there?
Oh.
Vintage 399.
Door.
Oh.
What is...
Is that a chandelier?
Okay.
A little bit of an odd layout, but...
How long has this meat been in here?
Did you make sure to get an inspection before closing?
I trust my gut.
Video games that you experience things you can't realize.
Stop!
It costs quite a bit more to furnish.
Really?
It's haunted.
You're literally a ghost me.
I'm not a ghost in the game.
I'm an...
I'm an elf in the game, okay?
Can I...
That nice natural lighting?
Some more Tamika Vintage 399?
Damn, Tamika's been busy.
Now, how do I see the ghost?
Gosh, sorry.
Okay.
I spooked myself accidentally.
Our very own bed?
That's our bed?
It's nobody else's bed.
It's literally ours.
And then this must be...
Oh, yes.
This must be the balcony.
And now we stay...
We stand up here as the...
As the wistful maiden of Anvil.
Everyone, there's legends about her.
They say that she's so beautiful.
That every man wants her, but she will accept no one.
And that she just...
Stares off into the distance...
Waiting for someone to fulfill her quest...
Of...
5,000 gold.
She wants her money back.
I said...
Surely, my...
Sighs will catch the attention of...
Some...
Someone...
They just couldn't hear me.
Yeah.
They just...
They just couldn't hear, you know?
I get it.
How do I...
Get furniture and like clean...
How do I clean this place up?
Like, how do I pick up stuff...
To...
Straighten it up?
I can pay an installment, right?
This place is kind of bizarre.
It's like...
Very...
It's not an open layout at all.
It's all completely linear.
You just go from room...
To next room...
Oh, wait!
I missed the door.
Is this a basement?
What are you sighing about, fair maiden?
I spent all this money on this house and...
Who lit those?
Oh, wallet-o, wallet-o.
Where art thou, wallet-o?
Oh...
You got ants?
I think those were worse than ants.
How good this place comes with spoons.
Dang, this is huge!
Some corn!
This place was made for me.
A light-o.
Sealed portal!
Open?
Open.
It won't open.
Spend the night here?
It's my home, of course I will.
What's the magic word?
Shasmin!
Where does it go?
Portal 2?
Portal 3?
Portal 3 is real?
Okay, let's sleep for...
12 hours.
We're actually...
10 hours.
Oh!
Wait!
They're actually attacking me!
Oh my god.
Wait!
Ah!
Wah!
Oh my god!
Um...
I can't...
Let's see...
My bow is not enchanted anymore.
But I can use silver bullets, right?
Silver bullets?
Silver arrows!
Do you know those guys?
Not every ghost knows each other.
Get Wawa's vacuum!
They're still here, right?
Oh yes.
Yes they are.
Hello?
Oh!
They see me.
Hello?
This is my home!
This house ain't big enough for three ghosts.
Four ghosts.
Someone said silver arrows will work.
I don't know.
Maybe I got one guide.
Who knows?
Make them pay rent.
Are they coming?
They're just chilling in my room.
It's worth...
A shot!
Oucha!
Oops, shoot.
Oh gosh, they're tough.
See, this is what you're getting when you mess with me.
Holy cow.
Oh sh...
If I had aim...
This would work.
Okay, we got one.
Rid of one...
Ouch!
Rid of one guy.
Rid of two guys.
They're ectoplasm.
Wait, so...
Will they come back every night?
Or...
I was awakened by ghosts that attacked me as I slept.
As I awoke, I thought I heard a crash from downstairs.
I should search the house...
And investigate...
Oh no, I'm not trying to sit.
No, no.
Get up.
How do I...
Wait, get up.
Wait, uh...
No, no.
Get up.
Someone's...
How do I stand?
E?
Oh, thank you.
You...
Showed those...
Spooky...
Yeah, I did...
Wait.
Ectoplasm.
Is...
Is this gonna disappear?
Or...
I sure left a little mess, huh?
We got some ectoplasm.
Yummy, yum.
Oh!
Skeletal hand.
Uh...
I thought it was going to be the portal downstairs.
I didn't realize it was this thing.
Whoops.
Oh!
Scrap from Lorgrin's Diary.
I found a skeletal hand next to a page from a diary.
Wait, wait!
Uh...
Spoilers!
I'm trying to read the...
The diary makes mention of a secret room in the house that only a true blooded...
Venerys can open.
I'm going to need to talk to Velwyn about this.
I may have to ask around town to find out.
Where he's gone.
Reading someone's diary?
Well, they left their hand in here, too.
I think we're already on a pretty...
Um...
A pretty, uh...
Intimate level.
And I think I can read their diary if they, you know...
The people of Anvil are worms!
Whoa!
How dare they criticize what they don't understand!
I shall have my vengeance in a form they cannot possibly imagine!
I shall use the souls of the departed to prolong my own life!
The tomb is very specific.
I must have more bodies!
Yes!
More bodies!
Wilhelm is not alone!
Wait!
Is he...
The real beller...
Bell...
Bellerino that we need for the home?
Sun's Dawn E...
3...
Plane of existence!
Is there gonna be like a boss fight in my basement?
Only a true blooded...
Ben...
Benerish...
May open the portal.
So if I fail...
However unlikely that may be...
A descendant may attempt to follow in my footsteps to carry on the true way!
To make sure our secret is safe, I have harnessed the spirits of those whose bodies I have defiled!
To forever guard that place!
Nah, no way!
Oh, okay.
So yeah, I have to fight a boss in my basement?
That's cool!
That's fun!
Great!
Wait!
I didn't get my arrows back!
I used all those silver arrows!
The fools think I don't hear them speaking!
I can hear their rumor and innuendo!
They intend to meddle in powers they can barely comprehend!
They call me an old fool and shun me!
The young dare each other to step one foot in my yard!
I have become the stuff of old wives tales and campfire stories!
Wait!
He literally became what I wanted to!
I want to be the legend of the town as the...
As the...
As the balcony maiden!
They dismiss me as an oddity, but soon they will see!
When all of Anvil lies invoiced around me!
When their corpses litter the streets and their blood dampens the earth!
Only then will my true power be unknown and feared!
Okay.
So I'm gonna stand outside my home and...
And sleep!
Luckily we don't need to sleep because I have no...
Level up!
But uh...
Wait...
We need to go talk to who?
Oh wait!
No, no, no!
I don't want that one!
No, no, back.
We're still...
Here, here, here, here.
Is it...
I don't see a...
Velwyn.
Who the heck was that?
Is that the guy that I bought the house from?
I don't see a red arrow, so I'm like, hello?
Why can't I run?
That's what I was gonna do, I remember.
Switch back to the steel.
Hello there.
Oh, it's because I was sneaking!
I'm stupid, sorry.
Greetings to you.
Greetings!
Get out of here before you get hurt.
What's wrong?
What'd I do?
Are you the worm?
You're the worm!
Do the worm, Wilhelm!
Do the worm!
Little does everybody know, when he was a kid, he used to do the worm all the time.
And that's where he got the nickname from, but now people just associate him with...
being a worm.
I'm Wilbur, owner and proprietor of the Count's Arms.
We make beds and food available to guests.
Can I help you?
Where's that man?
Where is Velwyn?
As soon as you bought the place, he pretty much up and left.
What?
I hear tell he's making his way to the Imperial City.
Why did he leave town?
Leave me alone.
Why do you hate me?
Okay.
Gosh.
You do a silly dance once 15 years ago and it becomes your entire personality.
Pretty much.
Kids are cruel.
Okay, we're off to find this guy, I guess.
Why?
He's never going to get business like this.
What if I one day didn't want to stay in my house that was...
10 feet away and instead...
Hello.
Oh, 3,000 steps?
Nice.
What if instead I wanted to stay in a hotel just for the experience, you know?
Kind of like when you stay in a hotel in your own city.
Just to feel like you're on vacation.
I don't know.
So, to the Imperial City we go.
Here, specifically.
The Elven Gardens District.
You into elves?
Subaru Natsuki!
Welcome to Membership!
Thank you!
Do you do that?
If there's like a convention in my city...
I think most people do that, no?
I would rather pay a hotel than pay for parking.
Are you in here?
No?
Really?
No.
Sorry.
You look like someone I knew.
I don't know my own...
...strength.
Pardon my butt.
Velwyn!
Wake!
Get up, mister!
Velwyn!
Blurious!
I'm surprised to see you all the way out here in the Imperial City.
I stalked you here.
So, you think I'm responsible?
I suppose you're right.
As the manor used to belong to my grandfather, Lorgren Beneris.
Beneris.
I knew there was a curse on that place, which is why I sold it to you so cheap.
Look at his face.
I suppose I should have warned you, but I had to get out of Anvil.
Why?
My family said I could move here to the Imperial City once all our loose ends were tied down.
The manor was one of those loose ends.
Okay.
I fear my own greed got the better of my judgement.
I hope you weren't hurt badly in that horrible place.
I've lost half of my silver arrows.
Because I assumed you'd be able to lift the curse and be done with it.
Yeah, well, help me.
Lorgren Beneris was a strange old man, always dabbling and experimenting with magic.
Why is he giving me the stink eye?
It was mostly harmless until the fateful day he came across a tome bearing the evil magic of necromancy.
Necromancy.
He became obsessed and decided that by using necromancy, he could prolong his own life.
The dark arts contained in the tome called for him to dig up the recently deceased in the nearby crypts under the cathedral.
When it was discovered that he did this, the Mages Guild called for a quick meeting to decide what to do.
It only took minutes to decide.
Led by a young upstart named Carrahill, the Mages Guild stormed Beneris Manor and slew Lorgren.
Slew?
However, amid the chaos, his body vanished.
How?
Because of this, the people of Anvil concluded the manor must be cursed.
It is.
You are the first person to set foot inside in a long time.
Oh.
How is the cheese... is the cheese still good?
Lift the curse!
According to the diary entry, it seems that I'm the only one who can open the secret door in the manor.
Did you just say you have family?
You are slightly guilty selling you the place under these circumstances.
I'll meet you in Anvil at the Count's Arms.
From there, we'll try to lift the curse together.
Okay.
Hope you're doing well.
I have good news.
I finally had a successful career mode run with Rice Shower!
Oh my gosh!
Congrats, Eric!
Wow!
I'll see you in Anvil.
Okay.
Oh.
He's getting his head start.
You forgot your...
You forgot your sack!
What if we just walk with him?
Necromancy may be legal in Cyrodiil.
But he will admit to practicing it now that the Mage's Guild has banned it.
Oh, where'd he go?
There he is.
Let's walk with him.
Venerous?
The faker?
I'm so hungry.
Ah, he's faking it.
Blessings of Mystara upon you.
Okay.
Well, let's go to the main gate, I guess.
What a faker.
Gosh!
We're phony!
Big ol' phony!
I'm so hungry, Minto.
Stop faking it!
Stop being so dramatic!
Mystara.
Mystara- Khan.
He's so hungry.
Oh, gosh!
Sorry!
Hail!
Why are you coming up to me?
Don't talk to me.
I'm here for a while.
Oh, you!
Wait!
I'm ready as I'll ever be.
No, no, no!
Talk!
I was half expecting you not to show up.
Are you ready to go to the manor?
Yes!
Then, let's get this over with.
I don't relish the thought of spending too long inside of the manor.
Follow me.
Okay!
How do you do?
Everybody's talking about...
I'm leaving.
Alright.
Surely this will end well.
I'm scared!
Not gonna lie.
Hi there!
What's going on with you?
What?
Let's get to my house and let's quick save.
Oh!
I thought that was the rat lady.
Wheeam!
There he is, our hero.
There he is.
He's...
He's walking.
He's coming.
He's got that stride.
He's got that pep in his step.
He's...
Where is he going?
Hello?
Wait.
Is that him?
Okay.
Here he is!
Thoughts on ship loot art with other girls?
I can't stop people from...
Drawing what they want to draw.
Though I think it...
I think the most curious thing is...
How many people get my chest size wrong.
But that's okay, I guess.
Where...
How do you get up here anyway?
Where is he going?
The house is right here!
Where?
Oh, he's taking the back entrance.
Oh, wait.
There's a little staircase right here.
Oh, okay.
I've just been jumping.
Alright.
What?
Velwyn and I have arrived in Beneris Manor.
I must proceed cautiously to the secret room's entrance and prevent any harm from befall...
Oh...
Oh, no.
Is this a...
Is this an escort mission?
Oh...
Wait...
I...
I spent money for this!
Oh...
I...
I paid for an escort mission.
5,000 gold.
I quicksaved outside.
No way, but if they're ghosts, I don't have enough silver arrows.
I have a dagger, will that work?
Use the dagger.
Oh gosh, it's good.
Hopefully, we can make it to the basement without too much fighting.
Don't say that!
That's why the damn layout of this house is so weird.
With the Sufferthorn.
This one?
My dagger.
It's enchanted, so...
I just don't want to waste all my silver arrows.
I don't get them back.
The frog shatter is such a funny name.
Anything enchanted works.
Well, this is enchanted, so...
I only have a couple other arrows.
Oh wait, shadow hunt?
Wait.
But I thought my bow was not enchanted anymore.
Hold on, I am going to use...
Wait, I don't think I can repair it, can I?
Oh my...
Hello?
Where are my...
Where are my repair...
I just have this dude's hand in my inventory.
Oh, this lockpick?
It just ran out of juice.
That's why I need the souls.
Okay, got it, got it, got it.
But does it still count as enchanted then?
Probably not, no?
Oh, it does?
What then I...
Oh, here it is.
You cannot repair items.
Okay, let's just go with the dagger.
I quicksave, so we should be okay.
Oh my gosh, don't stand so close.
Taking all this ectoplasm...
Taking all this ectoplasm though, it's kind of worth a lot.
Eh, eh, ah, eh.
Eh, there we go.
Excuse me.
This is the one I just killed, no?
Oh, this one?
No?
This one.
Okay, well, in to the basement.
Nice guy.
Oh, this one's also kind of...
It's pretty far to the...
Oh.
Oh my gosh, there's so many guys in here.
Oh
my gosh.
Let's get this over with.
What's happening?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Ah, what's happening?
Ah!
Don't die on me!
Oh my gosh, I'm going to die.
Ah!
Holy cow!
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Potion of healing.
Let's just, uh, take a couple of those.
Okay.
Um...
What does the feeble vine do?
Oh.
Oh, it's a poison.
Can I...
What is...
You cannot drink any more potions.
My tummy is full.
Okay!
All right.
Uh...
Block and talk.
I don't know how to block, actually.
What is that?
Right click?
Wow!
Memorable, man!
Thank you so much for that time again.
Thank you!
Welcome back, wandering zero.
Thank you so much for nine months.
Okay.
Right click.
Oh!
Whoa!
What?
Excuse me!
Oh my gosh.
Please, get me out of here.
You'll never take me down!
Wait!
I...
I didn't...
Oh...
Oh, shoot.
Do I need to...
Oh, no!
Please!
Let's get this over with!
Oh, no!
No, no!
How do I stop this?
Reload!
Oh, I have to go through all this over again?
Okay.
Ah...
I should have quicksaved after we finished the...
First part, though.
Dang it.
Block and talk.
What does that mean, though?
Okay, I have to...
Oh, put your weapon away and talk.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dang it!
All right.
Stay out of my way, please!
Hopefully we can make it to the basement.
Please stay out of my way.
Please.
Please, Velwin, stay here.
Lead on.
You stay.
You stay right here.
Lift the curse.
I hope that whatever's behind the door would truly lift the curse.
You can block and eat him.
If his disposition is high, he will forgive you.
Did you hear a noise?
Yes.
Can I block the ghost attacks?
Time to see.
Nope.
Okay.
Where's the other ghost?
Here.
Oh, shoot.
Hello?
Ah!
Velwin, please!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
All right.
Ugh.
I crashed my car last night!
I hope you're okay.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
We're fully healed again.
Lead on.
I don't think he'll stay here.
This place makes me uneasy.
Let's tread wisely and make our way quickly to the basement.
Ugh.
Did you hear a noise?
Yeah, he won't stay.
I think we gotta...
Okay, I'll just quick save here.
Okay.
All right.
His hair is glitching out.
Let's just...
Just oblivion things.
All right.
I'm scared.
Just kidding.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my gosh.
I was gonna say he didn't come through with us.
You know what?
Okay, what I'll do...
Is I will...
Use...
The silver arrows...
And then...
Yeah, I think I'll just use the silver arrows.
Can you tell him to wait?
It does not seem to be the case.
No.
So there's three there, and then there's one guy over there.
I see.
Just the steel arrows?
I guess we'll try him.
Oh, it worked!
It did work.
Was it because of my bow?
Okay.
I'm gonna have to learn how to repair my bow.
Nice!
Okay, awesome.
I see that one right there.
On the map.
Don't know where he is, though.
It seems that is the only one.
Okay.
Do steel arrows also get consumed?
They do.
So, you know what?
I might just use my iron arrows.
Yeah, that's the same guy.
Okay.
Hello?
Let me take your ectoplasm, please.
Can I quick save here?
I can.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
All right, all right, all right.
Ah!
Well, we found the ghost.
The other guy.
Yay!
Oh!
All is well now.
Are you safe?
You look unharmed.
You ready?
Okay, guess so.
Belwyn and I arrived at the secret door.
Do your thing!
Okay, I can't do anything.
I can't do anything.
Uh.
Lead on.
No, you.
I'll be glad to get this over with and get back to the Imperial City.
As soon as this opens, I'm leaving.
Yeah, me too.
Oh!
Belwyn successfully opened the door to the secret room, which has stopped the ghost from attacking.
Then he...
He then ran off, leaving me to clean up the mess.
It's up to me and me alone to investigate what's beyond the mysterious portal.
Oh, he's...
Uh.
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
Don't you want to say hi to your grandpa?
Oh!
I got some mushrooms.
Fresh from my basement.
The Tome of Unlife.
It's got two pages.
I see.
And some tongs.
Interesting.
I don't want to step in that.
Looks like the music is too whimsical for what's going...
Activate!
Wait!
What do you mean by that?
Oh, yes.
The candle in the casket.
There's so many little...
More bones.
What is that?
Oh, it's a sack.
Resist poison on self?
Thank you, grandpa!
Nice.
It was that one, right?
I wish I could tell.
Yes.
Skelly's also got some...
Got some stuff.
Well, okay.
Do I have to activate it?
Or...
Can I just...
Do the ghosts keep attacking me?
Every night?
I mean...
Like...
Save?
Oh, I have.
I will.
You have a corpse in my basement.
It's just...
It's just Halloween decoration.
It's free XP.
Why not?
You wanted a haunted house.
I thought that it would be like...
A regular Joe.
I thought it would be a guy who would be like...
Hey, buddy.
Like a...
You know, like a typical...
Ghost in a top hat.
And he just like...
Wandered around my house.
I didn't expect to get attacked.
Ketou, thank you so much for the farm.
Ketou, thank you.
If ghosts keep coming...
It's a training feature.
Just like having an exercise room.
And...
You got an ectoplasm farm.
You're so right, honestly.
I didn't know the ghosts would be evil.
I don't go to your house...
And haunt your place and...
Leave...
Well, I do leave ectoplasm...
Sometimes.
If you...
If you bought my mug...
There's definitely ectoplasm on that.
But you do.
Okay, but I don't attack you.
Always.
I just possessed you and eat your food.
And then...
Leave!
I don't...
I'm not like this...
Where I wake you up out of your sleep.
I'm not some paralysis demon.
Unless you want me to be.
That's what I stepped in last night.
Grave robber minky.
Okay, well I saved.
So let's check out the damage, I guess.
Activate.
Activate?
Oops.
Activate!
Uh...
Oh, the panels?
I am Lord Grin Berenice.
And I desire the chance to atone for my sins.
The things I've done to the people of Anvil.
The horrible, unspeakable acts I've committed.
Demand repentance.
Dary was justified in his actions.
Oh, he's changed.
This is character development.
Was the only way to stop the madness.
I have accepted that fate.
Now, so I may make my final peace with the Nine.
Please, reach with my hand to my body.
Only, when I have believed in this eternal Nine.
I don't know.
That doesn't sound very convincing.
After touching the altar, I heard the voice of Lord Grin Benerice.
He said he wished to atone for his past and make peace with the Nines.
All he wished was to be whole again.
This must be the way to lift the curse from Benerice Manor.
I should touch his skeleton while I carry the bony hand and put an end to this madness.
That's kind of sus, no?
As a fellow spirit.
Um...
Hmm...
Oh yeah, there.
This hand is missing.
It never fails to lose me.
It never fails to manipulate.
You've assisted me in completing the very thing.
Carrie Hill and his cabal sought to prevent all those years ago.
Uh-oh.
My...
Ascension to immortality.
Uh-oh.
Last time I clashed with battles, I underestimated their power.
I shall not repeat that mistake twice.
But he's just a skelly, right?
Oh, shoot.
Ah,
don't summon skellies, please!
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
What's happening to me?
Oh, I did it.
Completing the skeleton was a ruse!
And Lord Grin rose from the dead.
I had no choice but to destroy him.
With his destruction, the curse of Venerys Manor was lifted.
I should return to the Count's arms and speak with Velwyn.
Oh, shoot!
All he has is bone meal.
You've been dead.
Oh my god, my health.
Do you see that?
I almost died!
I have one HP!
Are you just gonna stay here, or...?
Cool.
Free bed.
Okay, I was gonna say...
I could really...
Uh...
Take his stuff...
Oh, he's got his bone meal.
He ain't got nothing else.
I did take his...
His staff.
Oh, I can't read.
Wait, where's his staff?
Oh, this one.
Staff of flame.
Take his stuff.
I mean, staff.
Aw, my house is a mess.
Actually, this kind of feels at home, though.
Oh!
Whoa!
Why is this still here?
That's my...
It's like such a hazard.
Free tomatoes!
Crystal ball.
Is all the Tamika still here, or...?
I got some gold-trimmed shoes!
Outfit?
Wow!
He fixed my house for me!
The ectoplasm is empty.
I took all of it.
Check the door.
Office.
Wait, there was a...
There was another door?
Oh, my gosh.
You're right.
Guide to Anvil.
The Eastern Provinces.
Oh!
Wow!
Fancy!
I didn't even see this before.
Check the bathroom.
Now, I really don't think there's a bathroom in there.
Yeah, see?
These are empty.
They're just decoration.
Now.
If you put stuff in these containers, they don't despawn.
So, if I put some grapes in here...
Put some leaves...
Oh, I thought it despawned.
Containers.
Oh, wait.
Will the containers...
Despawn?
Wait till after the quest before you put stuff away.
It might despawn on completion.
What?
Really?
The furniture, not the ghost.
But what if I don't want the ghost to despawn?
Nice.
Cop, cop, cop, cop, cop.
Thank you, Kappa.
Don't put stuff in the ghost.
No!
I
don't want them to despawn.
No!
I don't think we can control the ghost puddles.
But...
But I just said if I'm like...
With the here...
I like it.
I should be able to...
It's my house.
And then...
Will I...
Lose my new roommate?
She's still there, right?
Okay, good.
Lord Grin, don't leave me!
I just...
I'll just leave the bone meal.
I'll leave it!
So that he...
Stays.
He won't leave.
I believe he'll keep trying to give me the bone meal and I'll say, I'm sorry, I can't accept it.
Then what if I give him something?
What if I give him some grapes?
Only one, though.
I like to eat the rest.
I gave you a snack!
You're not allowed to leave!
It's still here, at least.
Kind of?
Okay, yeah.
I really wanted a ghost roommate.
I didn't want to defeat them.
Bad!
If
I were your ghost roommate, you wouldn't attack me.
Even if I summoned Skellyman, would you?
Everybody's talking about the Prophet.
After the attack on the chapel, people are inclined to believe almost anything.
Of course.
Good day.
Goodbye.
It's been 87 years, you gotta let go!
He was grandpa!
Calling the ghost buzzers.
No!
I think running runs in their family.
Family!
Okay, I'm over it.
The lifter of curses returns!
I'm sorry for running away like that, but fear got the best of me.
Well, I killed your grandpa.
I'm glad you talked for him to come and with you.
Now that the curse has been lifted, I feel like I've taken care of my family's unfinished business.
Excellent work, my friend.
May the mana give you many years of happiness.
I'm now off to the Imperial City once more.
Farewell.
With how everybody glitches out of this game, it feels like everything is my delusions.
Like, nobody is actually truly here.
I feel like I'm not playing...
The scent is unfamiliar.
I feel like I'm playing something, like I'm in the Matrix.
And like, reality is falling apart at the seams.
The mana is finally cleansed.
Yeah!
Wait, hold on.
Enjoy the mana.
It suits you well.
Thanks!
Enjoyed to hear that you were able to cleanse the mana.
Well done, my friend.
Thank you!
Wait, how's our friendship?
100!
He loves me.
Why don't you...
Velwyn.
18 a single.
Okay, bye.
Good fortune to you.
You know, if you reach level 100 with me, then I would...
Crawl into your skin.
And...
I would make a home in there.
Everyone is talking about the prophet.
After the attack on the chapel, people are inclined to believe almost anything.
Ash.
They say...
Ah!
Sorry.
Timothy!
Oh no!
Without question.
Bye.
Take care.
Whatever you're looking for, I'm sure I don't know how to find it.
Oh my god.
Are you the one haunting my house?
Who are you?
Val Morvayne.
Been making weapons and arms here in Anvil for 30 years.
People say I do good work.
Do you take bribes?
And I don't aim to argue with them.
Nobody has ever gotten past level...
9...
10.
Level 10.
So no.
Good luck.
What rumors we got?
You're the one they call the Hero of Kvatch, aren't you?
I am a Hero of Kvatch.
Going to close the Oblivion Gate and save the city?
Okay.
Oh, he will re...
Wait, will he repair my...
I can fix whatever you break.
Can you repair this?
25.
Actually...
Yeah...
Well...
What...
What is it at?
It's at 43.
Yeah, repair it.
Okay, good.
Okay, cool!
Well, since I can't repair that myself...
Leave me alone.
Why?
I just paid you!
Tidying, citizen.
What?
Is it because I made him work after hours?
Goodness gracious.
Let's go to sleep in our bed and not get attacked for the first time.
Well, guys...
Oh my gosh!
I can't believe we actually got our house!
It still has...
Ectoplasm in it.
If I sleep though, I'm afraid.
Let's sleep for...
Eight hours.
Bribing for extra disposition.
I'm not a ghost that can be bribed.
Good morning, my home!
You think I could bring like a lovely lady back here?
This bed is big enough for the two of us.
Good morning!
Time to sigh on the balcony.
Hold on, I'm doing my morning greetings.
Before he leaves, I think we should take some pictures.
Wait, hold on.
Let's take off our hood.
Hot dog!
Hey there, pretty ghost.
You're staying hydrated?
Blue, thank you!
I will in a second.
I actually just finished my coffee.
Okay.
You guys take some pictures.
I'm gonna go...
Get some water.
Hold on, let me fix the angle a little bit.
No, no.
Me and...
There we go.
Okay.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Actually, I realized I also wanna be in the picture too.
I wanna be in the picture!
Oh!
Itina, your hair.
The three of us!
It's the three of us!
Hold on, I'm gonna get rid of chat.
And...
Notice too, for just a second.
It's the three of us!
Hold on.
We're living together.
The two ghosts and an alien.
But she's not an alien.
It's the three of us!
We're...
It's a new sitcom!
We are living in a house together!
And we go on crazy adventures!
And then...
Maybe sometimes...
He leaves...
Lo...
What's his name?
Logan?
Logran.
Logran leaves some ectoplasm and he said...
No, Itina says, Hey, who left ectoplasm on the toilet seat?
And...
I point at him and he points at me and I go...
Not me!
It was him!
And...
No, no!
Classic Logan...
Laugh track!
Ha ha ha!
And we...
Know...
Itina thinks that...
That...
We don't know that...
She is an alien.
But we do know...
She thinks that we think that she is a...
Of...
Elf.
But we know...
Cause...
Of course we do.
The perfect sitcom!
From...
Lord...
Grand...
Paul...
Okay, never mind.
The joke is ruined.
I don't want to live with that!
Ew!
Get out of my house!
Oh!
We're getting into cinema.
Okay.
See you later!
Oh!
Sorry!
I forgot to bring you guys back!
Come back to me!
We're zooming!
Run into the wall!
Okay.
There we go.
Where is my...
Oh, there we go.
That was weird.
My mouse was like...
Acting weird.
Okay, cool!
Yeah!
Now what do we do, you guys?
What other quests do I have?
I forgot that Q does not go to quest.
I love how oblivion lets you set your own goals outside the main mission...
Or main quest.
Congrats on the house!
Thank you!
Let's see...
Dunbaro Cove.
Wait, what's...
When the vow breaks?
When the vow breaks...
Oh, this!
An unusual mace named the Rock Shatter.
Who is Maeva?
It's not giving me any...
Any red arrow.
Go back to looting that fort.
Yeah, we could do that.
Where did you find it?
In here.
In the fort.
Fort Strand.
The chapel.
You're back and in the house?
I guess we're no longer...
Apartment!
She's at the farm outside of Anvil.
Okay.
Who will take up this holy crusade?
Who?
Oh my!
To what do I owe this honor?
I am but a humble prophet.
What business do you have with me?
Um...
Nothing, I think.
Actually.
Hold on, guys.
Let me make sure...
Let me check when my next stream is.
I think I know.
Uh...
Checking my schedule.
Okay.
In an hour and a half.
Think on this.
What happened here...
Is only...
I'll probably play for like another...
Hour.
Let's hear it.
Okay.
To the farm!
Farm outside of Anvil.
Anvil's farm.
The farm.
The farm in which...
Resides a woman who...
Is an anvil.
The anvil lady.
The anvil farm.
That farm.
Anvil farm.
This is the fort.
And then we find the farm.
Farm.
Farm!
Farmville.
I never played Farmville even once.
I don't know.
I think...
I didn't play any of those Facebook games.
Hello, hello, Minto.
Hello, hello, Brandon.
If there's a...
If this is a farm...
Yikes.
It's not very well kept now, is it?
The door is locked and no one seems to be home.
Oh!
The door is locked.
Look at all them blueberries!
Well, why aren't they home?
You were more of a Newgrounds cow.
I...
Uh...
I know I should not admit that.
But I didn't play...
Normal games on Newgrounds.
Is that a cemetery?
Cemetery!
What?
A cemetery plus...
A cave?
It's the smoke hall!
Whoa!
Wait, dude.
Do you think there's ghosts in here?
Whoa.
I can't tell are those people...
Is that a person right there?
I can't tell.
Is that a person?
Right there?
I can't tell.
Looks like it.
Nope!
It's a rack!
Oh, I see it now.
I hear something that sounds like breathing.
This place is pretty spooky.
Ah, it's a rock.
I did hear breathing.
It was the ghosts!
I've had my fill.
Cool!
Uh...
Not cool.
Why is the music still happening?
Stop throwing snowballs at me!
I don't have that power!
I can't believe he followed me out!
I'm obsessed with me or something.
Gosh!
There's like a fellow ghost and she's so cute!
I gotta shoot my shot!
With a snowball!
Or something.
What's that up there?
Well, I think I've been there before.
In broad daylight.
I know!
Golly!
It ain't easy being me.
The dog!
I said what I said.
Oh my gosh.
Well, I was trying to do that quest with the...
I really wanna get rid of this thing.
Well, I gotta put my hood back on him.
I wanna get rid of, uh...
The...
This rock shatter.
Oh wait!
It's not heavy at all!
Just kidding!
Huh!
I thought it was gonna be a million pounds!
It ain't easy, bangerine!
It's hard being so cute because...
...mocked by a wolf.
Quest items are weightless.
Oh!
That's so smart!
Well, I don't know where to go with it.
They just act like I know this Melvin lady.
Okay, well then...
What do we do now instead?
Let's see, what's a different quest?
Paranoia.
Oh, I still gotta do that one.
I gotta go...
Let's kill Tutius Sextius.
North of town?
Did I have the wrong farm?
I'm south.
North.
Wrong farm.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Uh...
What's this?
Oh, this is like one of the...
altars.
Oh!
And there's a portal here.
Would you look at that?
Is that a dog?
Dang it, that's close.
Dang it!
Don't move.
Don't walk.
Dang it!
I got him.
Took me a couple tries.
Thank
you, thank you.
I appreciate it so much.
Guys, is it bad that like...
my least favorite part of the game...
is...
I got a lockpick.
Is going into the oblivion portals.
Is it bad that I like doing everything else...
with the actual game?
That's normal?
Is it really?
You're not alone.
Like, I feel like I could do every side quest.
Did it... did it register?
The portal?
Did it register?
Is it on my map?
Oh, it is.
Just kidding.
Okay, goodbye.
I don't want to fight any goblins.
There's...
two of them.
Two portals.
Oh!
I just said!
Why can't you listen to me?
My...
my wants and my needs.
Stupid.
I got like 200 hours in Skyrim, but I'm on mission three.
Wait!
That's the inn.
Is it more north?
I remember going to the inn before.
Oh my gosh.
Damn it!
I can't live in peace on this...
damn hell of an earth.
I didn't mean to take the pelt, but whatever.
North of town.
Okay, I'll go back.
Let's go athletics.
Okay.
I'm heading back to town and then we'll head north of town.
Uh oh.
Ah!
I'm lagging and I'm dying at the same time.
Um...
That guy just got on a horse and ran away.
Is that a friend?
Yeah.
We're right by the stables.
He's gotta be.
What is it now?
Oh, okay.
Leave me alone.
Oh no, I'm starting to sound just like them!
I'm starting to sound just like them!
Where they greet me and I say, Don't talk to me!
Are you- Oh, Maeva!
Oh, damn.
Yalfi!
Who- Who would leave you?
Fighting's easy.
Just lead them out on the water and shoot them full of holes.
If you've got a bow, of course, and can walk on water.
Yeah, she's single.
Let's go.
You think she's gonna take it well?
Probably.
Goddess!
You have rock shatter already?
And what's become of Yalfi?
Yalfi's such a cute name.
I called him Bajalfi, didn't I?
I don't- I don't know, no.
I don't care to know you.
Mint obliffated, probably.
Sorry, Maeva.
He's dead.
Here, here, hold on.
I'm putting my arms out.
Come, come, come.
Sob on my shoulder.
It's okay.
He was a good man when I married him.
But greed took a hold of his heart.
Oh, his greed seconds me.
While I'm not happy he's dead, I'm glad he's at peace.
Well, I'm just glad that it's all over and rock shatter is back where it belongs.
In my family.
She used glad two times?
I feel I only use something for your efforts.
She just learned about her dead husband?
Hmm.
Yes.
I feel it only appropriate that you have my dowry.
I would consider it an honor.
Don't you get that when you marry someone?
Maeva...
She's proposing?
You're in?
Does she like me?
This better be good.
Not really.
Do you think I would have gotten more money from her if her disposition was up?
Well, bye.
May the goddess watch you.
Yeah, she is.
Holy cow.
Focus on the...
There's nothing to rake there.
You need help harvesting?
I don't think she was very sad.
At all.
She said, I'm glad two times.
About...
Once learning that her husband is dead.
Vivicar, thank you so much for the gifted!
Glad.
She's glad glad.
Well...
That was the shortest quest ever.
Can I get my horse back?
I wonder where he is.
Hello, Ernest.
If you're looking to buy a horse, go inside and talk to Klisa.
Ooh.
You need to learn how to blink.
Stop talking.
I don't have my weapon out!
Why does everybody hate me?
Oh my gosh.
Lord Grouses!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
I'd rather not.
Thank you guys!
How do you do?
Welcome to the Horse Whisperer.
Oh my god, you did it.
Are you interested in a horse?
Are you guys related?
We have the finest white horses in Cyrodom.
None are hardier.
And only the black horses of Chadenhall are faster.
Hmm.
How much- Four thousand gold!
My house was almost that much.
Then you should start saving for it right now.
Alright.
You too.
I didn't say anything.
Why is it so expensive to exist here?
Who's this guy anyway?
Pinaris and Ventius, hunter, woodsman and marksman at your service.
Oh.
Plenty of deer, wolf, boar, mountain lion, bear in the county.
Just need to know where to look for them.
They don't...
They don't think they like the inhabit...
Inhabit your skin thing.
No.
Who wouldn't?
Seven months?
Just found these.
Hi, bitch.
Hello, Mayhem.
Thank you for seven months.
He can train me.
Teach, if you're willing to learn.
Into a marksman.
Wait, I think I'm good though, right?
Oh, yeah.
I'm better than you.
You too.
Alright.
Let's go back to our quests, everybody.
Let's go back to our quests.
We have many here.
This is a main quest.
I don't care about Joffrey.
Seeking your roots.
Join the Maiden's Guild.
I already bought a house.
I don't need to buy another one.
There is Glarthur.
There's always Glarthur.
The Elven Maiden?
Armand of the Thieves Guild asked me to steal the bust of...
La Tassa.
From...
Cheyendo.
Maybe we go back to the Brotherhood.
Maybe we do...
Oh, yeah.
We turned into a vampire.
I forgot about that.
Glarthur.
For Glarthur, was it just Sextius Tutius that I needed to...
Kill?
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Tutius Sextius?
Atashi Vampaiya.
Was it just him, or...
I can't remember if I killed the other two.
Actually, I don't think I killed the other...
Wait.
Also, one of the brothers.
Okay.
Yeah, I know I at least killed the lady.
Let's go double check.
Da-da.
Skin Grod.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
I think I remember I killed the brothers...
And then I got caught...
Not for killing, but for...
Um...
For looting, and I had to restart.
I think I remember that happening.
It was raining.
Hello.
Tilmo.
Yeah, hi.
It does make it hard to remember.
I had to...
Start and restart so many times.
Okay.
It was...
It's only showing me one.
Two sisters.
Can I go through here?
Alright.
Nice.
Skinny.
I have to go through there?
I remember you tried poisoning them.
Um...
Yeah...
What if I poisoned their food?
What the?
This is where I just came from.
What is it now?
Oh, they're here?
What if I killed them here?
He's on his horse.
Where is my horse?
Wait, he's like kind of far out, no?
It's you.
Hi.
Bay horse.
What?
Ah!
Nothing.
Good day.
You can put a poison apple in their inventory?
No way.
You can poison an apple?
Ugh!
And then reverse pickpocket!
Pickpocket!
Okay, hold on.
Let's just try this.
I just quicksave, so...
Where'd he go?
He's like kind of far, so...
Oh.
Damn it.
Oh, I think he sees me.
Oh shoot, he's like...
Jacked.
But if I kill him out here...
Nobody will know.
Oh wait, he's running away.
Shoot.
No, come back.
Come back.
Don't leave.
Wait, Tutius!
Tutius, I didn't mean it!
Oh shoot, I just got him into...
Nobody sees.
Somebody sees.
I don't know who.
Did I just...
Did I just do that?
Check your bounty.
Trill!
Trill.
Good thing I quicksave, right?
But nobody's coming to get me.
Who saw?
And if they work up the horse...
You saw.
If...
I am a free!
If they...
Oh, whoa, whoa.
If they saw it...
They don't care!
I'm a free elf.
I could pay it off with the...
Thieves Guild, right?
Wait...
Is that somebody there?
Oh, it is.
Do you think they saw me?
No survivors!
No...
No witnesses!
Oops.
Why am I so bad at aiming today?
Over...
Overestimated that.
Usually, I'm pretty good at sniping.
Today, I can't...
I can't get it at all.
Pretty penny.
What you got?
Oh, wait.
Why am I doing all of this?
Wait, I guess if I go...
Okay, hold on.
So, if I go to...
The...
The guild...
If I...
The horse, I think, really...
You guys, the horse is following me.
I think it really is my witness.
Look!
Look, it's still staring at me.
I think the horse is actually evil.
The horse will attack me!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This is...
Umamusume.
Kimi no aiba ga...
No!
Don't leave.
Don't leave now, you coward.
Look at these full of holes.
I couldn't maybe get away with this.
How is it stealing?
They're mine.
Wait, do they count as...
I might be able to get away with this, you guys.
I don't remember though.
It was the Imperial City.
My game is starting to lag.
Probably because I'm doing evil deeds.
If I...
I could maybe get away with this.
Me when my Uma fails with streaming.
Your infamy still goes up?
I don't care.
Yeah, I'm infamous.
I'm part of the Dark Brotherhood.
Oh!
I'll swim there.
I'll swim, I'll swim.
I saw a guard.
I don't know if you guys saw him.
That's why I...
That's not my horse, is it?
No, my horse had crazy armor, I remember.
Okay, he's gone.
Okay,
he's gone.
Sextiest tootiest!
Oops, sorry.
Dang it.
It's worthless to me anyway.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'm so sorry.
You have been caught...
Make it quick.
You don't like me anymore, do you?
Cast out of the Thieves Guild!
You have been cast out for mistreating your fellow Thieves Guild members.
In order to be returned to the roles, you must make reparations.
Are you ready to pay the fine?
My bounty!
Wait, hold on.
I'm still raising the money.
Then I have no use for you.
Be gone until you can pay the fine.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
We can...
Okay, load...
The odd...
Not...
The quick save.
Oh, wait.
It didn't autosave when I...
When I teleported?
Hold on.
It didn't autosave when I fast traveled?
Okay, hold on.
It was right before...
Okay.
I have to hope that...
I didn't get...
Spotted.
I will not make the same mistake twice.
Okay.
We can do the same thing we did before.
Except...
When I walk up to him, I'm not sneaking.
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
Everything, this is...
This is fine.
Okay.
I'm not sneaking.
Talk.
Good to see you again.
Okay.
No big bucket!
Pay off my fines and bounty.
You can pay your fines to the guards, serve your time, or pay me half, and I'll fix them all.
How much gold do I have?
It's your prison sentence, not mine.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait.
Huh?
Uh-oh.
Shadow hide you.
Oh, wait.
That's not my gold.
I'm broke.
Okay.
Hold on.
Uh...
Sell the staff!
Oh my gosh, yes!
This...
Staff of flame!
Okay, who liked me?
I'm trying to think.
Uh...
Who was...
There was a guy that I sold really well to.
We do?
We?
Ah, you guys silly!
You guys are so silly.
Dude by the docks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a...
We go to Anvil.
We will make this right!
Okay.
Anvil.
It was the dock gate, but we'll go to the lighthouse.
I'm too scared of getting caught.
There should be no guards here.
I don't think there's any guards around though.
It's so over!
It's so over for me!
Who's attacking me?
It's a pig!
Please!
I'm just gonna drown myself in the water.
Guys!
What do we do?
There he is!
Am I still getting pursued?
By the pig?
I think I have to F9.
And then not kill Tutius Sextius.
I think I made a grave error in judgment.
What is that?
You think he'll come get me in the water?
That Mr. Pig.
Alright, will you guys teach me how to do a poison apple?
Will you guys teach me?
Should've never listened to Glarther.
Look, we're gonna get our money back!
From the house!
Well, not all of it.
But we're gonna get a good amount back.
You can buy them from the Brotherhood.
No kidding?
Alright, we'll do that.
Alright.
F9!
Ikimasu!
It hurts.
It hurts!
Can't you just kill Glarther?
Wait, where is he?
Oh, where am I?
Oh, there he is!
I was so scared for a second!
Oh my gosh, you're alive!
Okay.
Alright, let's...
How do I buy from the Brotherhood?
I guess, uh, that one town...
In...
The mountains.
Coral?
Was it...
It was coral, right?
The...
The place...
That I could...
The hideout.
I don't think I've ever been to the hideout.
Here?
Oh, the Brotherhood!
Sorry!
I was thinking...
I'm stupid.
I was thinking, um...
I'm so silly.
I was thinking of the...
The Thieves Guild.
Not the Brotherhood.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's why I was like, huh?
I've never been to the Thieves Guild hideout.
Let me in!
It's been a minute.
It's alright.
Thank you.
I always forget all these names, too.
Hey there, Skelly!
Dark Guardian?
Ah, Mr. Hair.
Mr. Rogaine over there.
So sad.
And we searched for that lion guy that hates us.
I know.
I remember.
You?
No, no.
Is that the rat I hear?
He he he he.
Yeah.
Mr. Toupee.
I just, you know...
It's not that I'm shaming him for wearing a toupee.
For wearing a wig.
You know?
Do what makes you feel good about yourself.
But it's the fact that...
He looked so much better bald.
Bald is beautiful.
This is his room.
You can shame him.
He's probably in here.
Thank you, Minto, especially as someone who is balding.
Hello.
You again?
Yep.
I thought I'd made it clear.
I am not looking for a friend.
If you are here to buy or sell something, get on with it already.
Can I still persuade...
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Bartering.
You have...
Poisoned apple!
It's expensive.
Wait.
I can sell...
Will he...
Well...
It's only 186.
Can I still haggle?
I don't know.
I can't change his disposition at all.
I don't think I could do 60%.
It's 100?
What if I do like 66?
Oh, it doesn't change that much.
I don't have that much money.
If I sell...
Wait a second though.
If I sell the staff...
If I can sell it for 216...
I will have enough.
Poisoned apple.
Here I come, baby.
Oh...
There we go, okay.
And then we'll make more money.
And then we will...
Buy another one.
Yeah, I do need to.
I have...
Way...
I could sell the tome of end life.
I don't need that, right?
It just had two pages.
And the cave diver's helmet.
That's true.
We do have that.
We do.
Sell it after you read it.
Just take your trinkets and go.
Ah, you love me.
Foul-smelling ape.
He loves me, he loves me.
Uh...
How do I read it?
I thought I did read it.
See, this is all it is.
It is a fun accessory though.
Kinda wanted in my house.
Anyway, okay.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Let's go poison...
That guy.
What's good is once we...
Once we poison the other people...
We can kill Glarther and nobody cares.
We can kill Glarther...
Rob his home...
And get lots and lots of money.
Alright.
Back to...
Here.
Yeah.
Now where is he?
Up there?
Yes.
Why is this town so bizarre?
Oh, he's home!
Okay.
I'm just gonna save again.
I might be able to...
Peek pocket.
Hello?
Yes?
What?
No!
That's what I have to ask you!
Bye.
Are you gonna...
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe when he saw me before...
He was just like...
Wow.
She's so beautiful.
You're not gonna commit on me, are you?
You're not gonna...
Oh my gosh.
Tootie is sexiest.
You're so close.
I'll come back.
No time.
Oh!
It's red now.
It was not red.
You guys saw...
He locked the door.
I see.
Well, there's the other person.
The brother.
We could get the brother first.
We can knock him out.
What time is it?
It's 10am.
I'm listening.
Maybe I just...
I...
It was a...
I came too early.
Ma'am, he's not into you.
You were just trespassing.
He ran down those stairs.
I don't know.
He seemed excited to see me.
Maybe.
I don't know.
That's him, right?
Okay.
I always wanted to poison a brother.
This is him, right?
Wait.
Hold on.
Now I can't remember the guy's name.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna kill an innocent man.
Wait.
Inspect.
Go to the sexist.
We killed the lady.
Yes.
Okay.
David.
Now I...
Give him the apple.
And now we would.
Oh my gosh, we did it.
I think he has other food to eat.
Oh.
Take his other food to be sure.
As bread.
I wouldn't take it so bad.
I will be good.
Okay.
Ha ha ha.
Hi.
Now how long until he gets hungry?
For a little snack?
Hi.
I really wanna take his gold so I can buy another apple, but...
I wanna watch...
Okay, okay.
You can take it off his dead body.
True!
It's my birthday tomorrow, in case you don't stream tomorrow.
I'm gonna...
Oh!
Game Tavern!
Happy birthday!
I think I'll stream tomorrow.
I forgot to tell you guys.
I have my...
My, um...
Throat doctor appointment this week.
So...
Hopefully...
Things are okay.
I will be good.
She says that she plans to murder a guy.
It's all part of the job.
I have...
Don't hate the player.
Hate the game.
Now I gotta get the tube down my throat.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Brave.
I hope I don't throw up.
I don't have that fear of throwing up.
But I don't wanna throw up.
I hope I...
I hope I get good pictures.
The gray fox protects you.
Bah!
Don't look at me.
Good morning.
Where'd he go?
Tiding citizen.
This way.
Um...
Uh oh.
Wait.
I can't go inside.
And I'm being watched.
I wanted to watch it.
I wanted to watch him eat it.
Quick save.
Oh!
I went in.
I'm David of Surili Brothers Vineyard.
Gaston is my brother.
From our vineyards come the finest wines in Tamriel.
Hmm.
Finer than Tamika's?
Damn!
Yeah, well, in all honesty, no.
But our wines are very good.
And much cheaper than Tamika's very fine product, I assure you.
Rumors.
That Danas Artelian is a little too full of himself.
Sure, he's a captain of the guard, but I'm not impressed.
Are you hungry?
You too.
Okay, I don't think he wants me in here.
I hear a Nirn root.
Excuse me, sir.
I just want to inspect.
Wait, isn't it in here?
Oh.
Nope.
It's not.
Ugh.
You think I can make it over there?
Huh.
Oh, we're at the lodge.
How many times is this Nirn root going to get us?
Look, it's been a while, okay?
It's been a while.
Well, I guess I can make some money.
Or find ways to make money.
Um...
So that, uh...
We can go buy the other apple.
You know?
I don't have time for you.
I'm a customer!
Well, not really.
Actually, how do I get out of your establishment?
Where is the front door?
Ma'am?
I'm lost.
What?
How...
How do you...
Am I missing something?
This is the basement.
Second floor.
Second floor basement.
Up here?
Oh!
Uh...
Oh?
Wait.
No, I'm out.
I'm at the...
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way.
Hey!
I found it.
When will we get the notification that he...
Oh.
What?
Okay, hold on.
I'm just gonna do it myself.
What?
Uh,
I thought this was the door that went to the...
Ah...
How do we know for sure the guy is gonna eat the apple?
I don't know.
I'm being watched upon.
I quicksaved earlier, though.
Wait, is that Glarthur?
He's not gonna...
He's not gonna rat me out.
I quicksaved earlier, before we went into his house earlier, so...
And I didn't do anything, so...
Ah, no!
What?
We'll see.
Ah!
For the love of Azura, can't demand a bit of privacy?
Get out of here!
Sorry.
He was waiting for me!
I see.
Okay.
No.
No, no.
No, no, no, no!
Not again, please!
Bye!
Oh, I do have enough money.
Haha!
You can!
He did see me...
Lockpicking.
Oh, shoot!
How are you?
Hello.
I have another stream in 30 minutes.
Well, guys...
I...
Oh!
I wanted to see him die!
Tim, Tim, thank you!
Streams have been helping me feel better.
I'm so sorry for your loss.
Glad I couldn't help a little bit.
But...
Itina looks like a Uma when sprinting third person.
She does!
We're never gonna get...
I feel like...
I will only finish this damn Glarther quest...
When I finish Oblivion.
I feel like this is the final boss.
This stupid quest.
Dang.
Well, guys, I have another stream in 30 minutes.
But it is a Membu stream.
So, if you also wanna come watch a movie with me...
Movie...
Sunday night movie.
We're gonna be watching Legally Blonde.
Cause I wanted to watch that movie.
Cause I saw somebody watching it on the plane.
And then I would...
Fall asleep.
And I'd wake up.
I'd be like, where are they at?
Oh, they're at this part.
Sorry, I'm falling asleep again.
I'd fall asleep, wake up, be like...
Oh, they're at this part of the movie.
Fall asleep, wake up.
Murphy!
Thanks for the vibe, Grypton.
So...
Hmm.
Legally green.
Yeah.
It's...
C2!
Thank you for the vibe, Grypton.
Si Si!
Thank you for the Grypton!
Mariel, thank you for the...
Welcome to contrary finding assessments, thank you.
Harry, welcome back.
Thank you so much for fifteen months...
Thank you.
Hunter, thank you for the Grypton.
One month until one year.
Thank you!
Spike!
Let me jadi a little bit hmm, this is your question.
Well...
Um...
Oh my gosh, these three hours flew by.
We did a little bit of cave, dungeon diving.
A little tiny bit.
We...
We did some quests.
We got our house?
That was huge.
We finally got our haunted house.
Yeah, that was a big one.
The words legally blind made me join me.
Thank you.
West English Face, thank you so much for the five.
Valentine, thank you so much for the ten.
Come watch Legally Blonde.
Have you never seen Legally Blonde before?
It's a really good movie.
Targo, thank you so much for the five.
It gets in.
Prince of Denmark.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the Akosupa.
One of the Senna, congratulations on all your recent successes.
I loved watching you sing with Kiara.
We have had some W's lately.
Okay, so thank you for the five.
Bloodless, thank you for the ten gifted.
Thank you for the three.
We don't can't wait to watch a movie with you.
I'm excited.
50 empty.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Hard working ghost.
I'm trying.
Zest, thank you for the five gifted.
I can be unlucky ghost.
Some times.
Did you tell me so much for that doggy gift?
You're doing great.
Thank you.
I'm succeeding.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for the 20.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go watch Legally Blonde in a half hour.
I gotta make a way to move.
Thumbnail, but I'm lazy.
Thank you so much for everything.
Thank you.
Thank you for so much.
Thank you guys.
Well... Um... Um... Uh... I think... Wait.
Hold on.
I shouldn't be sitting here with... Hold on.
What are we gonna do?
We're gonna wait a whole 12 hours.
And see if he eats within that time.
Happy birthday!
Seriously?
It's you.
Hi.
I don't know who you are.
Uh... We're going to wait another 12 hours.
Yeah, I know he has food at his house, so... I guess we'll see.
Is that Glarthor?
Um... No time to talk.
Okay.
Wait.
Is that him right there?
Dang it.
I was about to bust into your house.
No.
Well met.
No!
Eat!
What's wrong with you?
David, you'll always be...
You got to put some muscle on that bone...
Mister!
No!
Check if he still has it.
He better.
I spent 400 gold on it.
Here he comes.
He's running at me.
I think.
No, he's not.
He didn't notice.
Wait.
Where is he?
Not... Not out here.
Yeah, he still has it.
Hmm.
Maybe I should take his other food.
Let's steal his other food from the house.
Alright.
A people's princess.
What if he doesn't like apples?
Hello.
Do you need something?
I do.
I need some money.
Can't you see that I'm very busy?
So long.
Glarder is so rude.
I can't wait to kill this guy.
Ha ha ha.
According to the wiki, he has respawning bread in his inventory, so he won't eat the apple.
No way.
Greetings.
A small number of NPCs are effectively immune to poison apples because...
because they carry a self-replenishing supply of food.
take it back.
No time to talk.
No.
No!
I...
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna F9 again.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just gonna go inside.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm seeing if he's running downstairs to us.
Sorry.
Why didn't he run down before?
I don't understand.
Hello.
Goodbye.
This is too difficult.
Let's hear it.
This is so tough.
Okay, but the only one who sees me is Glarthur.
Okay, he doesn't see me anymore.
But he wouldn't... he wouldn't snitch, right?
He wouldn't snitch, right?
Get out of here.
Okay.
I give up for today.
I give up.
For next time, let's remember to get the apple and we'll give the apple instead to...
Tutius Sextius.
I should have given it to him to begin with.
I should have just gone with the original plan.
Dang it.
Well, thank you, guys.
Whoever...
Searched for me that...
That...
We couldn't...
That he had the re...
The respawning bread, so...
I can't believe...
I can't believe he's going to live.
Tutius Sextius lives another day.
If only I had enough money to pay off my bounty.
But, you know...
We can't live in what ifs.
This is an insane setup you got going on here, buddy.
Okay.
Well, anyway.
Thank you, guys, for more Oblivion.
This was a lot of fun.
I will see you guys...
Maybe in a bit.
And if not, in a bit.
Then I'll see you when I see you next...
Otzavito!
Otzavito.
Do I go?
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, as always...
All the donos...
And all the members...
And...
Everything...
Super chats...
Thank you for watching!
Thank you for hanging out with me!
And I will see you when I see you next...
Otzavito!
Iってらっしゃい!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye...
Buh-bye!
Bye!